all right let's do one let's do a quick
question okay so I'm just going to do if
you have your calculator there by the
way this would be useful I'm just going
to do a couple of conversions with you
okay so for example they're still really
easy let's convert 11 days in two
minutes okay just suppose I want to know
how many minutes are there in eleven
days okay before you tell me the answer
how am I going to use this to help me
what am I gonna do with this room okay
think carefully
minutes are really small units are thick
compared to days anyway so my number
should it get smaller or bigger should
get bigger there's lots and lots of
minutes not many days so I should be
multiplying
do you see why I'm multiplying well it's
gonna be huge now before I get there
something how does this diagram tell me
what to multiply by someone told me how
to use this diagram before they tell me
you'd answer cuz that's the important
line which you get to be using days and
minutes so to get from days to minutes I
have to multiply by 24 and then I have
to multiply by 60 does that make sense
so now I can write this down 11 times 24
times 60 Center is 950,000
50
thank you okay
now 11 times 24 times 60 that looks
about right to me okay so that is the
number of minutes in another nation okay
so that's good
I thinking for beginners too small you
that's different okay so there's my
first example let me give you another
one
and I'm going to use our calculator
either give you a bit of a trick what if
we wanted to go from children's to 75
minutes in two hours this is a very
couple of minutes two hours okay now
look at your diagram these are the two
units I'm using by going the other
direction now right
so should I multiply and divide I should
divide okay so I'm gonna go to 75
divided by 60 now my calculator I
already did this my calculator when I
hit equals okay it gives me a decimal
can someone read out maybe four or five
of the decimal places that they've got
Christian and keeps going right keeps
going good okay now in normal language
right if someone to tell you if I said
to you how many hours is gonna take to
do X right no one talks in decimal when
they describe time right well very few
people right so I don't like this
I don't want it in four point whatever
hours I want this in hours and minutes
that's a normal way to do this okay so
how am I gonna convert this extra bit
suggestion it's pretty close to four and
a half isn't it but that's some really
big rounded you've done right and not
only is it big rounding I've actually
rounded it wrong cuz it'd be four point
six yellow bits close isn't it okay so
I've got a better trick for you okay you
got your calculator
yeah
I can't reach it you got close on your
calculator I want you to remember this
really cool button we used mainly
mothers are doing angles it's above the
button on my cake that says Eng right
do you remember what that other button
it's called it's got a circle and some
poppers on it what's that button called
it looks like this right what is this
button chord I told you what it was
called you remember look at the symbols
you need to write this down since no one
could actually remember this button is
called the degrees minutes seconds
button right in fact on some calculators
some of you might have it the button
doesn't look like this it says DMS which
stands for degrees minutes seconds okay
now watch this make sure you've got that
four point five eight three three three
make sure you've got it on the display
and then just hit this button and see
what the calculator tells you if you've
done it right if you're looking at it I
think it should say something like this
four and there's a degree support and
then 35 I think and then there's a dash
and then is there anything after this
can you see anything is a zero zero
it's just not people looks like wait
what's five nine what zero yeah I'm
getting it done something different
okay so what's this button done right
this bun super cool it's done this thing
you see this right
it's said huh point five eight three
three three three of an hour point five
entry
how many minutes of that and it's just
question for you it's just up with that
however that's got a degree symbol when
everything goes here we're measuring
time okay so my hot Sun I need to
convert is this is the answer the answer
is four hours and 35 minutes okay so
there are other ways to do it but by far
that's the quickest way and I'll show
you hours later